which are serious
and as faithful as any that the United States
are ever spoken in the five and a half years
that I have represented to the United States
in the Security Council one event which precipitated
and increased the necessity of these sessions of
a Security Council was the overthrow of the
government of Iraq this is because it made
it clear that there is in the Middle East a
common purpose to take over everywhere all
at once clearly there is a common purpose
masterminded from one source you can read
all about it in the car or newspapers or listen
to the incessant radio broadcast from Cairo to
other Arab countries in fact the prominent Cairo
newspaper is openly urging the assassination the
presidential move that is the kind of thing that
we face today the the technical obstacles are not
the main point we face a great rough-hewn
facts the facts of the fomenting of civil
strife by assessments in plain clothes instead
of by soldiers in uniform make no mistake about
it my colleagues history will hold us responsible
we cannot avoid an answer to the question here's
the United Nations to condone subversion in
plain clothes controlled from outside of the
country if the United Nations cannot deal
with indirect aggression the United Nations
will break up but this could surely do the rap
on which this organization could found them